die stadt wesel in nordrhein westfalen
steht unter schock ein ultraleicht
flugzeug stürzt ab mitten auf ein
wohnhaus das haus steht nachher sofort
in flammen und bei diesem tragischen
unglück sterben drei menschen darunter
auch eine mutter eines kleinen mädchens
kristina k war mit ihrer tochter noa zu
hause als plötzlich ein flugzeug durch
ihre decke kraft das ultraleichtflugzeug
aus marl stützt am samstag um 14 uhr 42
auf das mehrfamilienhaus in wesel
auslaufender treibstoff setzt die
dachgeschosswohnung von kristina k
schlagartig in brand augenzeugen
sprechen von einem feuerball
die beiden insassen des flugzeugs
sterben in den flammen die 39-jährige
mutter erleidet schwerste verbrennungen
sie stirbt noch im rettungswagen ihre 18
monate alte tochter noa war in einem
anderen zimmer
sie kann aus dem feuer gerettet werden
jetzt ist sie bei verwandten
festgeschnallt auf einer trage holt die
feuerwehr am samstagabend die leichen
aus der ausgebrannten wohnung
am nächsten morgen erinnern blumen und
kerzen an die opfer dieses tragischen
unglücks warum das ultraleicht flugzeug
des typs t l 96 abstürzte ist noch immer
unklar
unmittelbar vor dem absturz war es in
wesel nach einem zwischenstopp erneut
gestartet nur zweieinhalb kilometer vom
flughafen entfernt stürzte es dann auf
das wohnhaus kurz vor dem absturz wurde
ein fallschirm am flugzeug ausgelöst der
als rettungssystem installiert war
im notfall soll er den leicht flieger
abfangen
die ermittler untersuchen nun was zum
absturz des flugzeugs führte